[Music]
so there was a uh a man who was charged
with killing a chinese delivery man over
duck sauce
oh man you gotta have ducks also and you
forget duck sauce though dude and but
one day but when they went through his
refrigerator his refrigerator was full
of duck sauce what the [ __ ] that's crazy
this guy's not
just nut he's just he's not nuts the s
was silent do you think he wanted room
temp duck sauce i think that's really
the question because once it gets cold
you know it becomes like uh wait i think
i heard of this [ __ ] spend time
trying to back up his logic real quick
wait try no this shit's kind of sad dude
i remember this one how'd this go what
was the situation so it is a uh this guy
is a condiment obsessed kind of random
dude he's a reporter he's a hoarder
that's the right one dude he's got taco
bell packets all over the [ __ ] place
nowadays you know what i don't care i
don't i don't understand i don't know
why this guy couldn't just go to the
market and buy duck sauce like why did
he have to get the [ __ ]
the the the plastic would they fill up
your [ __ ] it's like you could have got
the [ __ ] duck sauce yourself i think
we're asking the wrong questions
maybe it's more like why did he kill
somebody but i i can understand why you
would go there first we know why because
it's the duck sauce no it's a lacquer
nuts
no nuts
no no he's not
that's how i said it
criminal you have to get inside the mind
of a criminal
that's what i was i don't watch that
mine hunter [ __ ] yeah i'm saying fbi
this [ __ ] is fire
so this condiment obsessed queen's
murder suspect was a hoarder i don't
know if that's derogatory uh he ordered
sweet and sour duck sauce in his
refrigerator but um even though he had a
bunch he still got super pissed off at
this chinese food delivery guy and had a
feud with him that led to him uh
eventually kind of
stalking this chinese delivery guy uh
and on the day of his disappearance and
or murder uh was allegedly walking
around the restaurant multiple times
looking for him
and then eventually uh followed him to a
spot and shot him dude there's footage
of this i saw it um he was on a bicycle
after he did a delivery
and you see the guy going out and then
he's walking up and he just blasts them
point-blank
dude it's actually really sad because
they did an interview on um the store
owner and then they're and the store
owner was like crying and she was just
like we told the [ __ ] cops multiple
times this guy was harassing us he kept
he keeps coming to our business like
they did nothing so then
to me i was like dude that's when it
made it real like that sucks dude like
the cops can't do nothing because he
hasn't really committed yeah there's no
crime yeah but then
maybe they can get him on trespassing
maybe they can tell him like yeah like
whatever but i don't know what the rules
are behind that but there were multiple
times that they reached out to the
police and asked them to do something
and then it wasn't until after they
killed like they that he got killed
where they were able to catch him and
all that but that's that's kind of what
sucks police said they've been building
a case against this dude his name is
hirsch uh so after he kills someone
they're like we got him now
they didn't have anything else besides
him like following because they were
learning he had been involved in ongoing
tensions with the manager at the great
wall restaurant which is another
restaurant um
[Music]
this was starting in november the crazy
guy when he was yeah when he was fierce
there wasn't enough duck sauce for him
to take home from his meal on that one
so he was already in a feud with that
um and then yeah you're right though joe
like you can't really
there was nothing on him you just was
pissed off and bothering them because
you wanted more duck sauce so you know
what we need to do
we need we need asian we need asian hate
patrol like no what i mean by that east
coast version because we do that here we
do that on the west coast yeah we got
monterey park covered but what we need
is like these two blocks at least yeah
the triads used to do this right where
you couldn't go to the cops but then you
told the triads like look there's this
[ __ ] nut that comes into the
restaurant and he's [ __ ] [ __ ] up
please do something
[ __ ] shrimp boy and he goes i got you
you know oh my god he comes up and he's
like hey you want to [ __ ]
at the restaurant [ __ ] [ __ ] say
the last part sooner please
no
wait you wanna [ __ ] that's not bad at
this restaurant if the guy says yes then
then you're really in trouble yeah
you're like all right can i stick this
in your
mouth
right the sad part is that that
protection racket is the crime
that is a crime because they prey upon
but it started
back in the day it started as an actual
protection like security group because
[ __ ] like this was happening in
chinatown back in the old days so it
started good got corrupt later damn it
always happened just like the boy scouts
we got greedy and catholicism
and government and government government
um this guy hersh uh actually had 10
previous sealed arrests and has pleaded
not guilty and is being held without
bail the rest
that's uh i don't know it's so it's like
on your record but you can't see what
it's like yeah that's what they yeah
they black out your [ __ ] uh your
record yo yeah why did they get that
right
it's like don't tell anybody you're
right criminals get all the rights man
they do
also not been charged with a hate crime
in this case because it's uh more of his
obsessive nature versus a uh because he
might be going to taco bell and starting
with them
no
he looks
he looks like a guy that works at a
bagel shop good thing he's wearing a
mask though yeah no seriously yeah good
things that's good
he's from queens he's from queens
where is he going to get his duck sauce
in prison now
that's true now we're asking the right
questions
now you're gonna get dick sauce
or duck dick
there you go
what's the prison price for duck sauce
don't feed the dancers you know they
gotta get it in there through the ass
right
we're chilling that's duck butter
children okay
damn man that sucks dude i i this is
this is when i feel like i miss
gangsters yeah
because you know like a lot of these
things didn't really go down because the
gangsters were too busy harassing the
restaurant not doing it like they used
to i know now you got crazy like did you
ever do that in your gang days no but i
knew people who did you ever break some
legs how's your chance bring the
councilman like do what you didn't do
before you know what the people that i
knew that the way that they did it like
so by the time it was my generation so
they did this like in the older
generation right by the time it was my
generation
everyone was just it was a racket like
an extortion racket everyone just knew
to go to the cafes go there hang out and
then they'll pay you and stuff and then
like the older guys did it i was too
young i was like 14 15.
but then um
it became to the point where like
everyone was just getting payments from
the restaurant and they weren't doing
anything to protect it sometimes even
causing more issues because they would
fight at the restaurant so i mean like
yeah that's probably what ended up
happening it's like they [ __ ] it all
up but i do know that in chinatown i've
heard of stories where like there would
be crazy dudes that would just come in
you know how chinatown was like a little
indoor plaza right where they had uh
just like t-shirts five for ten dollars
all these things right fruit stands
and then there'll be guys that will come
in
i guess like crazy dudes that would just
grab things throw them up like fight
with the people right and then these old
gangsters will come out and then they'll
just have like
two guns in their jacket and they'll
just show them and then they're like you
want trouble and then they'll look at
them they'll be like oh [ __ ] and then
they just walk away
and i'm like wow that's a crazy story i
haven't witnessed it but i heard of it
so i don't know if it's real the legend
of you on tribal yeah you want trouble
that's why jackie chan always says i
don't want trouble
he knows he knows what he's done like
that's how he de-escalates the situation
before he i think it escalates the
situation honestly but he's like this
don't want trouble isn't that how like
because when when i was in japan and we
visited the red light district i
remember our friends were like hey when
you're like standing outside like if
you're hanging out outside of businesses
in the red light district if you're too
loud
or you're kind of like just joking with
your friends
like sometimes a guy will just come out
and just kind of look at you just to
make sure that she's shut up yeah you
just like kind of just monitor your
activity that's enough yeah and it's
like he's like oh that's like yakuza
basically what they do is like if you
attract too much attention then they'll
just like kind of
okay i love the nonchalance of like yeah
we're in japan we're at the red light
district and uh this happened of course
this is before i was plotting hookers of
course
about 15 to 20 minutes before
and the guy was still looking at me
so when all of us came out after our
blow jobs
and we were raiding our experience and
high-fiving each other
walking out like this
and then these gangsters came out and
stared us down and we're like well we're
not going to talk about our blow jobs
here
we're going to go over there to
yoshinoya [ __ ] wasn't that funny for
blow job anyway
my first time visiting the red lights
district uh as a tourist
in uh amsterdam my second time was not
uh in amsterdam did you see dutch
gangsters um i don't know but what i did
see was other than one dude who like
walks out of the door and he's like
sweating he's like oh and he high-fives
his friend which was
hilarious so good later on down the
street i saw this other this black dude
he had like one of his flip phone
cameras at the time and he was like kind
of like taking photos of his girl in the
in the booth and she was like no no no
no and then this [ __ ] huge other
black dude comes out like security
takes his phone rinse and hat throws on
the floor and pushes him away no way
he's like oh [ __ ] he ripped it in half
like that yeah because it was one of
those razors not the other one
this is like
it's back in like 2007. imagine if you
had the nokia brick
it's a sidekick flips it
dude
it's like the galaxy note 3 it's like
this [ __ ] big and it's foldable yeah
it's nice he flips open the sidekick and
cracks it in half dude i'll be sick dude
he flips over the side he sidekicks it
that's why you need a dummy phone for
the first time
that's how desperate you are for the red
light district photo
you go and then you go
babe i have two phones so that if the
guy breaks it when i'm in the red light
just trick it to my phone
it's a burner phone i'm taking pictures
of hookers why do you have two phones
you just start taking out different
things you take out a twix
just everything to split into
yeah
just like how about this how about that
otter pop
he's just perfectly breaking the hat
the there's a city and uh an otter pop
japan where they have the headquarters
for the largest mafia there i think it's
nakatomi plaza nakatomi plaza uh i think
it's kobe i don't know but it has a
hundred thousand members right and it's
it's actually rated the safest city in
japan
because no one wants to do petty crime
there because if you do petty crime
there it's like you're not going to get
caught by the cops you're just going to
get murdered
oh that's giving me texas wives
so it's like super safe so it's like you
have little grandma
you know walking safe in the middle of
the night our country needs to be run by
fear again
welcome to texas
welcome
all right see if you go
[Laughter]
[Music]
now